julien achard bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france vous avez décidé
d'ouvrir hier racontez nous comment ça
s'est passé est ce que vous avez eu la
visite des gendarmes
bonjour donc oui il hier nous avons
ouvert notre établissement nous avons eu
bien sûr la visite des gendarmes des
renseignements territoriaux de notre
préfecture
nous on veut plus nous étions mis
d'accord orientales avant que nous
sommes depuis trois mois de prêcher la
tête par hollywood après futur donc nous
avions eu l'autorisation de d'ouvrir
avec une sur la voie publique avec une
manifestation dont nous avons bercot
sable nous avons la chance dans le bain
devons plus avoir un temps agréable les
gens à consommer sur la voie publique
sur des manches le coût pour refaire un
petit moment de convivialité que nous
avions l'habitude de le vivre
auparavant voilà est-ce que vous allez
continuer aujourd'hui dans les heures
qui viennent dans les semaines qui
viennent
non le lin la joie du 1er février avait
été mis en place pour donner coup de se
battre pour faire savoir à l'état savoir
que nous étions maintenant pris à la
gorge que ça ne pouvait plus continuer
comme ça donc non là c'était un coup de
semences
là nous savons très bien que le
confinement de sorte de confinement va
être inévitable donc ce coup de semences
à va pas mettre savoir l'état qui donne
le temps pendant ce mois cette quinzaine
que nous allons accroître finalement de
prendre des bonnes décisions
car après cela nous allons rouvrir notre
établissement mythique et soi observe
normalement car ils n'auront vraiment
plus le choix juste en serre ont
justement en cesse d'alerter sur la
situation économique catastrophique de
nombreux restaurateurs dans quel état
aujourd'hui se trouvent les finances vos
finances de votre restaurant le pescador
belle et les finances nous
l'année passée band 3 5 millions euros
tu aux fermetures eu donc donc voilà des
finances ont pu par les pays eux s'en
sont attaqués comme on dit loin donc de
jour en jour les nous nous le comte
s'appauvrir elle est la valeur de nos
forums
ce décote et nous n'avons pas de
visibilité pour savoir comment tout ça
donc donc c'est le gros souci il nous
faut une date absolument de réouverture
clics et des vinyles parce que
concernant le fonds de solidarité est ce
qui va permettre de sauver votre affaire
est ce que déjà vous avez pu en
bénéficier
voilà moi alors on va parler clair et
net mon affaire mois les charges fixes
n'a pas beaucoup de travail la pluie et
qui ont été remis en préfecture
tous les mois j'ai 18000 euros de
charges fixes voilà je ne parle pas de
mon salaire et cela tu es ma femme nous
nous sommes donc un travail et je parle
de mes charges fixes restaurant 18000
euros par mois donc c'est à dire que
tous les mois de perdre huit mille euros
voilà une attitude et nous sommes
beaucoup les beaucoup de restaurants ou
les 10000 euros suffisent
ce les restaurants jusqu'à 235 mille
euros ou les restaurants ou déjà en sont
propriétaires parce qu'ils ont travaillé
pour ça ça suffit mais il ya toute une
une partie de nos restaurants de moi
j'ai 39 ans nous avons fait des crédits
les charges fixes ne nous avons pris des
risques et donc nous les assumons des
préconisations également de deux avec
ces risques là de pouvoir travailler
donc parce que c'était là la base de nos
richesses
on travaille on sait le faire on peut
rembourser nos crédits nos emprunts nous
nous n'avons pas besoin de travailler
ces deux là pour des restaurants qui le
peuvent par rapport au protocole
sanitaire par rapport à leur surface et
leurs yeux peuvent travailler et donc
donner ces aides au médical donné ses
lettres pour acheter des vaccins donnés
ces aides pour qu'ils aient plus de
personnes travaillant dans les hôpitaux
pour des services dernier à la science
voilà les aides pour répondre par mois à
4 milliard pour les restaurateurs
uniquement pour les restaurateurs parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres secteurs
d'activités que le tous mais nous ne
pouvons pas travailler et nous faire de
l'emporter mettre des plats de sacs et
donner à nos clients ce n'est pas notre
métier on a pu suivre les mésaventures
de ce restaurateur de nice on souvient
il a ouvert
devant les caméras sans masques
notamment il a été en garde à vue à
l'issue est ce que vous êtes prêts à
faire la même chose ce même type
d'opérations coup de poing dans les
semaines à venir pour alerter le coeur
et le foie
non nous nous nous avons dans la
restauration nous avons établi un
protocole sanitaire
donc ce protocole la sanitaires il faut
qu'ils soient respectés c'est ce qui m'a
permis
mais ce même protocole sanitaire nous
l'avons ont vu en moi de jouer et nous
avons travaillé donc eu ouïe soi-disant
en terrasse
mais je suis désolé pendant le mois de
juin au mois de septembre
il a eu du mauvais temps nous avons
servi à l'extérieur avec ce protocole
donc ils étaient bien adaptées ils
étaient strictes on est à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui vous pouvez manger de
partout en france sauf dans les
restaurants nous mangeons avec un petit
numéro points dans les restaurants
d'entreprise
nous mangeons n'importe où même dans les
avions nous avons un protocole adapté
nous pouvons le faire
les routiers sont réouverts certains
restaurants sont ouverts pour le btp
donc pourquoi ne pas faire des têtes au
moins intéressant alors pour savoir si
le 6e virus circule plus au nord et en
europe que dans les grandes surfaces
nous c'était une cohérence là des
grandes surfaces n'ont pas de protocole
sanitaire je suis déçu parce que de
l'avis des quatre faces mais les
chariots ne sont pas lavés les signé pas
de sens de circulation il pleut les gens
ne sont pas obligés de se laver les
mains
chez nous c'est une nourrice toi qui
sont à taille humaine bien sûr que nous
pourrons le faire tout ça donc il n'y a
aucun problème
voilà merci en tout cas julien achard
d'avoir témoigné ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes restaurateur et patron du
pescador c'est à l'isle sur la sorgue